so if you in the evening could sit down
next to a ball a tennis ball a softball
roller and ask yourself from the day
what store what hurts what's achy and
I'm going to commit 10 minutes the first
part of this show I'm watching I'm just
gonna roll around on whatever ails me
then the next sort of level there is we
could say hey can you take a full breath
in that position so if you're working on
something or you've got some aspect of
your body that hurts and you push on it
and that takes your breath away or you
catch your breath then we found an area
of interest and all you need to do is
take a four second inhale there
and hold that for four seconds and then
exhale a long time for eight seconds
long exhale and what you'll find is if
you just repeat that cycle a few times
whatever hurts in that area that you're
working sometimes starts to hurt less
and because you did it before you bed
you tend to sleep a little bit you're
down regulating